sometimes you just going to let filler
be filler eaters of light Doctor Who
episode 10 of series 10 and yeah I kind
of gave away pretty much almost my
entire opinion from the episode with a
little intro but it does very much feel
like a filler episode now there's
nothing inherently wrong with that I
mean sometimes you just need filler not
everything must contribute to the
overall thing or be a game changer or
anything like that but you can get
really solid really memorable standalone
stories and this isn't really that again
it's not bad by any means there's a lot
of little things that I like about it
but the broad strokes are pretty broad
let's go to hit a historical setting
let's drop in a monster let's have the
doctor fix it and that is kind of it and
that's a pretty bog-standard much of the
way that I felt like Empress of Mars was
a pretty bog-standard scenario as well
now I don't want to over quate the two
they do have very different fields but
they do both similarly feel very much
like filler and just a way to fill out
the season and none of the neither of
them really feel like they're exploring
anything too particularly deeply you're
trying to do anything all that ambitious
that says they accomplish what they set
out for well enough I do personally like
this one a bit more than Empress of Mars
maybe it's just because I like the
setting a little bit more I just think
they'd pick an interesting setting and
especially in terms of how much
surprising balance is given between the
Romans and the pics because on the one
hand you have this guardian of the gate
who very clearly kind of overstepped and
did something horrible and and there is
an acknowledgement of the contributions
to modern society that the Romans gave
and you know some surprisingly forward
thinking things over when times while at
the same time we can all think that they
sent 5,000 soldiers up to kill a whole
bunch of farmers in Scotland so it was a
lot more balanced than these things can
end up being sometimes so
that was nice there was it's funny when
bill had her whole thing of realizing
that the TARDIS was trans of the TARDIS
the doctor whatever is translating the
language for her the I Amiga really
we're doing this now almost done with
the season we're doing this now and then
I thought oh I guess she hasn't brought
it up before and it actually kind of
played into one of the moments that I
that I liked quite a bit which is when
the Romans and the place sort of
suddenly realized that they can
understand each other when they couldn't
before in the Solomons that they all
just sound like children having a
tantrum and I liked that moment I like
that acknowledgement it's something that
at least I'm not familiar with a Doctor
Who scenario because a Doctor Who being
dropped into the middle of a conflict
between two sides again not particularly
exceptional it's happened more than a
few times but I don't think there's ever
been a situation where it gets
acknowledged by both sides like hey I
can understand you when I couldn't
before and then what does that mean I
don't think the show's ever gone there
up it up to this point and it was just a
nice moment it worked pretty well the
characters Wow not especially
deep are not also as shallow as they
could have been under the circumstances
and their prey they're played pretty
well as far as the the supporting cast
goes the thing with the crows it's
really cheesy but I oddly kind of like
it I'm not sure I can explain why other
than to say I guess I kind of liked
cheesy a little bit I don't know the
monster was pretty neat I kind of liked
the light tentacles thing that it had
going on but it's how it functioned it
was very vague but that's not uncommon
for these sorts of situations where it
is just a monster as opposed to you know
someone with a plan or a society of
aliens or what have you so I should have
expected as much as what Empress of Mars
the best stuff though is with Missy at
the very end and I'm really really
loving Michelle Gomez in this part right
now and I'm loving how she's playing
this where it really does feel like the
character is finding new depths to
herself yeah
at the same time she's not losing that
edge that she is dangerous and there and
she probably should not be trusted
I love the doctor's reaction to that
we're hit him acknowledging like look if
this is genuine that's a big problem
because I shouldn't trust you and hope
is a dangerous thing when it comes to
someone like you yes in time you know he
is experiencing that hope I'm loving
that balance I'm loving that dynamic the
two of them together are so good and it
really makes me super excited for the
next episode and I think a lot of ways I
I came away from this going out that was
fine it was you know kind of
unremarkable kind of disposable it was
fine but like I'm so pumped for the next
one especially knowing that there really
got to finally get into the thing with
Missy and the doctor properly plus we're
going to get them onto Cybermen on top
of that which yes so again that's kind
of it I don't have all that much to say
about this one because I know I just
don't think there's all that much to it
it's mine there's nothing wrong with
this certainly as much as it is I would
qualify it as kind of a disposable
filler episode it's certainly not bad
there's none of the head slapping
moments of some of the worst of these
things to go with modern example
something like kill the moon had head
slapping Romans and the force of the
night for me Sleep No More had some
awful head slap moments this doesn't
have anything like that so it ends up
being fine it's just fine it's a
completely run-of-the-mill okay well
this will keep the the momentum going
until we get to the one that really
matters kind of episode and that's fine
I mean I would like them to I like it
when they take the opportunity of these
standalone filler episodes to do
something a little bit more ambitious
like you sometimes give us something
like mummy on the Orient Express or the
or the high-water mark is stuff like
midnight or blink but you know and
they're not always going to be that and
this was fine so I guess that's going to
wrap it up do what were your thoughts on
this episode or if you're like me and
you feel like you don't have a ton of
thoughts on this episode what are you
excited for for the next one so whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments and let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter right
counselor geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast also you can
hear me as one half of the punch like a
girl podcast both of those are available
on iTunes and stitcher and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]